the father of a young child killed in a
high-speed crash has now also been
arrested thank you for joining us
tonight at six
i'm kirsten joyce both parents of the
child now face charges for this crash
twenty-three-year-old lauren prescha is
accused of driving impaired
when she crashed into a marquee sign
killing her 22 month old son
the crash happened sunday at the
intersection of lake mead and rampart
metro police now say the father 23 year
old cameron hubbard jones is
also responsible christian drummond
joins us live from
the newsroom with the latest
developments in the investigation
kristen
kyrsten police are charging hubbard
jones with reckless driving
officers say he was also going more than
100 miles per hour on rampart boulevard
before the deadly crash
this is dash camera video showing two
cars speeding
hubbard jones was in a mercedes and
prussia in a hyundai according to police
officers claimed the parents were likely
racing each other on the street
police report prussia driving 121 miles
per hour in a 45 mile per hour zone
before hitting a car and then slamming
into a marquis signed support
with her son in the back seat a retired
metro sergeant watched the video today
he says a quick flash possibly shows the
moment of the deadly crash and says
the father is just as responsible as the
mother
why was he going fast there's no need
just because they're going going home he
doesn't need
he should have probably got on the on
the phone and said my wife girlfriend
what
whatever their relationship is has got
my child in the car and she is driving
you know extremely fast on this roadway
a police report says hubbard jones
claimed the two were in the process of a
custody exchange
meanwhile lauren prussia was in court
again this morning
her lawyer withdrew from the case and
another public defender is being
assigned
presche is being held on a 50-thousand
dollar bail and is due back in court
tomorrow
now a memorial at the crash site
continues to grow with balloons toys and
candles
many who don't know the child or family
tell me they've continued to come
out here or out there to pay their
respects a candlelight vigil for him is
scheduled for tomorrow night at 8
o'clock
at buckskin baskin park reporting live
in the newsroom kristen drummond 8 news
now